multiple polls now tell us that Donald
Trump's approval rating at the hundred
day mark is the worst since 1945 two
polls released yesterday a Washington
post/abc poll 42% approval for Trump an
NBC poll very similar 40% approval for
Donald Trump there's often sort of a
honeymoon phase at the start of a
presidency didn't happen for Donny boy
we thought maybe that the Syria bombing
would cause a bit of a resurgence in
Trump's approval rating and it kind of
did I mean we can't necessarily say it
was because of that but we saw a slight
uptick in Trump's approval from those
lows of 36 37 percent since the Syria
bombing there's an argument to be made
that were it not for the Syria bombing
that Trump's approval rating might have
sunk even lower but compared to other
presidents Trump is really not doing
well at the hundred day mark take a look
at this Donald Trump as I mentioned
according to the NBC poll at 40 percent
at the hundred day mark President Obama
was at 61 percent more than 50 percent
higher approval than Donald Trump George
W Bush at 56 percent and Bill Clinton at
52 percent you actually have to go back
to 1945 to find approval ratings this
low during a first term I continue to
find these numbers shocking Pat the
shock being that the numbers are this
high I mean it is utterly embarrassing
to me that 40 or 42 percent of the
country sees what Donald Trump is doing
is that I approve I think it's a good
job that he's doing and a lot of that
support is coming disproportionately
from white non-college educated men
which is you know apparently the group
that is going to be immobile in terms of
moving support away from Trump and you
have to go all the way back to 1945 I
mean the whole reason that Harry Truman
was unpopular from the outset was
because no one knew who he was
FDR had been president for 12 years and
he was replaced by this random
haberdasher from Missouri yeah so the
reason why he was unpopular was because
nobody know who he was Donald Trump
everyone knows who he is and no one
likes it yeah it's very clear that
there's a lot of people who aren't
liking him although his core supporters
seemingly unfazed
who has Trump helped so far what
geopolitical situation has Trump
improved what domestic issues has Trump
had a positive influence on the facts
don't matter to really appeal to people
you have to appeal to their morality or
their sense of justice or what was I
almost knocked my water over I'm getting
so agitated here or in some other more
visceral way because the fact checking
is not going to change this right Trump
has been a disaster and he has 40
percent approval
that's the disturbing part not that he's
so low in approval it's that forty
percent still say I like what he's doing
and the top accomplishment that he cited
from his first 100 days was the
appointment of Neal Gorsuch to the
Supreme Court yeah all he had to do was
pick from a list of names and get the
Senate to confirm his pick and even then
they had to use the nuclear option to do
it right is that even an accomplishment
for Trump when basically what he's
proved to us is that somebody gave him a
list of names and he was able to pick
one he was able to draw a circle around
a piece of paper somebody handed him and
say this is the person we're going to
select you know it's better than an
executive order that was overturned or a
piece of legislation that failed to even
be brought to the floor of the house
yeah there's another aspect of this too
which is that many so-called Trump
supporters they likely wouldn't express
positivity about what Trump has done if
you really dig in with them but there's
probably Trump supporters who just like
that progressives aren't happy with what
Trump is doing there's no doubt that
there there are Trump supporters who see
progressives complaining about Trump and
that makes them happy and makes them
support Donald Trump which is both sad
and low-energy I have to tell you it's
also one of these things where you don't
want to admit you're wrong and claim
that you made a mistake by voting for
this oh absolutely
no doubt a big rabbit